you consider yourself an
anti-establishment president of course I
mean like the definitional version of it
is who's the last anti-establishment
president you think we had outside of
trump
it's been a long time I mean I'm tempted
to say an element of Reagan was
anti-establishment but but only an
element because I think he was and I
respect him but he was prone to a sort
of compromise that
is a little bit of a I respect Reagan
he's a hero but slightly different than
my orientation coming in as a true
Outsider in this
there's there's a streak that Eisenhower
had towards the end of his presidency I
think it's what a part of him inside
that disgusted him when he gave that
farewell address on the
military-industrial complex absolutely
but I don't know that we will have had
an anti-establishment president like the
one that I intend to be for this country
and I think our moment uniquely calls
for it too because I don't think there's
been a moment in American history where
we've had the merger of private power
and state power to together do what
neither could do on its own I think that
is a uniquely
now 21st century phenomenon and so I
think that the times of the country
select for the kind of leader that that
moment calls for you think there's a
reason why we haven't haven't had one
for a while
you think that it's intentional you
think they know how to eliminate guys
like you to not be able to compete I
hope not well by the way if you're
talking about shutting down 75 I'm going
to eliminate this I'm going to eliminate
that the last guy that had that kind of
a plan he you know what I'm saying it
didn't go so high not too long he was a
good guy but we joke around about this
but you know we
it was a serious conversation as a
family in the states that we're in
to
step into the arena that we're stepping
into this isn't I mean we step into the
arena as an entrepreneur this is a
different Arena no question and you know
I mean
I'm a father of two sons we think about
these things very seriously my
obligation is to my two sons
but in a deeper sense of
not just showering on them some
inheritance right I don't think that
does them any favors we're putting you
know God ungodly Subs into this campaign
to lift this up but in a certain sense
that is the inheritance we want to give
them
is a country I want to be a president I
want you all to hold me to The Standard
where you can tell your kids and look
them in the eye as I want to tell my two
sons in good conscience
that I want you to grow up and be like
him whoever that is in the white house
it's been a long time
since I think we've had a president to
whom at least I could say that to my two
sons in good conscience and that comes
with some sacrifice
that was the tradition I was raised in
it's the tradition of this country the
judeo-christian values of this country
was founded on is founded on the idea of
sacrifice
of doing your duty at behest of
sacrifice and so we all have to look
ourselves in the mirror and ask
ourselves how are we going to make the
sacrifice we need to to create this
country I did not serve at the age of
22. many of my friends did I respect
them for it I went in to be a capitalist
and I think there are many ways to serve
this country and I don't apologize for
that I'm proud of it
but this is a phase of my life to say
how do we
create that country that I grew up in or
even better
maybe even a country greater than the
one that you and I grew up in
and I think yes does that involve some
risk and some sacrifice yes
that you can make a sacrifice you can
take a risk
if you know what you are sacrificing for
and that's the thing we call America and
that's what we've signed up for and
we're not going to stop until we see it
through who was the toughest person to
convince wife parents who was the
toughest person say honey don't do this
yeah what are you doing we're very
wealthy we have young kids leave it
alone we have a good life why do you
have to do this let the other 70 80 90
year olds run just to leave it alone
well I mean the truth is I have a lot of
people we
you know very blessed to live in a
family and a circle of friends who love
us very much and so the truth is there's
only one person I had to actually
convince who was my wife who was the
easiest person to convince and the rest
of them were unconvinced and did not
give me their permission even as of the
day I declared so they're now along with
us for the ride but you know my wife the
first question she asked me was
are you sure we don't want to do this 20
years from now when it's a great
question you're only going to be 57 yeah
it is your question are we going to have
more experience
and by the way our kids are going to be
out of the house sure and we'll be in a
phase of our life where this might be
more realistic
from a family perspective to handle
and
and honest to God my answer was I
thought that was a very fair thing for
us to reflect on I don't think we have
20 years left as a country actually not
if we stay on the track we're on right
now I don't think there's going to be
something left to conserve to save it'll
be something we'll be going through the
motions right we'll be
still a bunch of you know two-legged
higher mammals looking around the room
we got
you know different genders two of them
there's different shades of melanin okay
this is great we're diverse we'll be
two-legged higher mammals with a bunch
of different shades of melanin roaming
some Geographic space that we call a
country doing what iPhones told us to do
on a given day going through the motion
yeah but that's not that's not really
the United States of America that's just
the aimless passage of time
and I think there's more to life there's
more to this country than the aimless
passage of time and I think that
we call it the American dream for a
reason
and you wake up from a dream what
happens you forget what the dream was
about
you remember what it felt like for a
little bit
pretty soon you forget that too I think
that's the Zone we're in right now
so we forgot what that dream was about
we still remember what it felt like it's
a that's a fragile thing
I don't think we're working with a lot
of time here and so I think that sense
of urgency at poorva she joined me in
agreeing with that and also believing
that you know what
20 years now will be a little bit more
tired you know I don't know that I'll be
I don't know about that you seem like
you were fired up type of guy like
you're gonna find a type of guy but you
know we got we're we're ready for this
now and so I don't think we want to look
back 20 years and regret and say that we
missed our window to breathe the life
back into this country you are a
formidable opponent and and it's great
to see a guy like you come through the
way you handle debate sitting down with
Don Lemon he's trying to piss you off
and you're like look I simply disagree
with you but respectfully we're on
different pages the way you manage
yourself has been fantastic and as a
person that is as eloquent as you your
background your ethnicity your success
in your life Family Guy all of that
stuff it's exciting to see guys like you
coming up for for the entire political
side a lot of Republicans are happy to
see guys like you coming up you're going
to inspire a lot of 22 year olds right
now 18 year olds right now that are
going to say if this 37 year old can do
it maybe I can in the next 15 years I
think we do need a guy like you
competing it's a very good thing to see
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]